in this class you have built your own
framework and also use an existing one
but when you enter the workforce and
work on projects how do you know when to
use which it's a common problem that
you're going to be faced with so let's
see if Jacque has any advice for us hey
so there's actually a bit of a trade-off
in between using an established
framework like bootstrap or using your
own framework and when you use a
framework like bootstrap you're gonna
get a lot of features I mean as you can
see you know as you've worked through so
far you can build a tremendous amount
with bootstrap when you start to need to
do things outside of that framework when
you want to start doing things that
bootstrap doesn't support you might look
at making your own and when you make
your own you get a lot of freedom you
can do anything really but you're gonna
have to put in the work to do it so as
you approach your projects try and see
what that how that breaks down for you
if you're gonna need to do a lot of
things that boudoir bootstrap doesn't
support try looking at maybe rolling
your own if you're gonna be doing things
that bootstrap does or that another
framework does that you find that you
really like go for that absolutely at
Udacity we actually use a combination
between a bootstrap and some stuff that
we've written ourselves to work
alongside of it and that's pretty much
it
congratulations on getting through the
class so far and you know be fantastic
see you working on your own projects or
in you know at some point a professional
office like this